[Music]
late Jerry Mitchell Tina yeah yeah the
story the more a capital mundo Kanako's
a multi Bella
so no to Van Atta Marcia did he go in
club the Giulietta Verona
Grazia Shakespeare and teasing today
Steve is it at or even gonna Verona
Pella story drama Julieta the literal
Julieta
Arriba no the quasi to ditch and Tanya
Verona and phenomena visto increment Oh
Supra two-tone and amino Vonda later a
soda vent at Mei Yin Yin to Tel Aviv way
the SATA Laura K beyond open shot OD
Kralik Lobby Julieta
questo grupo de persona que se dedica no
Costa particular activity adi responder
a trade or a AR k VAR le malade emissive
a into telling ago del mundo solo
chickadee Jamila onion or queer some
responder left started then to modulate
at Jerusalem on a minute sir are
co-linear a responder a elementary que
que trabaja inquest Osito touristic
acara punta tombo de Julieta
in win it saw a responder a few Mendoza
in secretary usually take wind-resistant
attend West Omaha he continued
toldja his cleavage or later normalmente
a
problema the more queen the key day
consider Astoria see chair kadhi
responder and in your mouth the
possibility that a it Concilio giusto oh
come on we're on a parallel give me
cheat tsadikim prints on it you can
check toda more a great ocasion liver
salad then the litter possible the dare
the Shockers creep on a persona cuanto
la more se acabó convinced to tokuma una
della Casa P importante en la vita my
son Oh chica Trenton ek thi work in the
geometry the modern on a cambiado
importance the sentiment of the no more
Airy man and man Hank Romanian very
artists see an attempt ok Canelo's parts
are going to 2pi the moon
[Music]
so you think tinder is a recent
phenomenon what if I told you tinder on
paper existed back in the Victorian days
here's what happened way before hallmark
people use personal calling cards to
connect with each other
picture this it was the late 1800s a man
and a woman cross paths they exchange a
look in return the man passed his card
see Society at that time was very formal
and not satisfied of the stiff social
conventions youngsters got creative
enter escort cards the calling card was
a twist
think of the most ridiculous and cheesy
pick-up line you've ever heard written
on a cart come and see our new laughs
you can turn it down so low there's
scarcely any light at all PS our sofa
just holds two I'm just your size and
complexion I'm going in your direction
so if you have no objection I'd like to
be your protection
I am cy young who the devil are you now
picture that card slip to you it was a
way to flirt in public without anyone
ever knowing may I have the pleasure of
seeing you home this evening
and in this case oh she swiped left
sorry
[Music]
okay i'm louis and i'm charlie and we
have been told and we believe that we
have the largest private collection of
insects in the world yeah the story of
how we met was interesting enough i was
a teaching assistant at the university
of arizona and Louis was a student in
the class that I was teaching we've been
married for almost 55 years he's got a
million stories about insects all of
which I've heard and all of which I can
fill in sentences and we've traveled
extensively have been to all the
continents and 70 countries collecting
it fills us with pleasure to get into
the field and collect to spend the time
in the field together oh you need to
look at the antenna on one of these it
looks like a clown shoe well I study
weevils and the weevils are the largest
family of living organisms these are
plant hoppers and I think their noses
are too
I collect plant hoppers which are
insects that feed on the juices of
plants the foam or the xylem with
piercing sucking mouthparts with
piercing sucking mouthparts
oh yeah when when we get some insects in
they're just dead of course we have to
mount them so we have to pin them
our point points them and then we label
of the glue was not stiff enough and
he's fallen off his point then after I
do that then I sort him to genus each of
these units trays holds 55 specimens on
average and we have at least a million
weevils and a quarter of a million
dollars okay here you come darling
we are donating the collection to
Arizona State University and there will
be research done on it which is what we
wanted to have happen when we were
entomologists at the university we
worked 14 hours a day seven days a week
now we're down to eight to ten hours a
day seven days a week it's a lot of work
but we both loved what we were doing and
it was sharing that it was part of our
life yeah
which one do you think is the prettiest
these two I don't like that one Louis is
often taken note the fact that a very
large number of entomologists are
divorced what I recommend is if you're
going to be a taxon Allah systemic tests
collect insects you get a spouse it is
another entomologist
you
first time I met miss Louise never shall
forget it we met I had an eye you know
and that must have been love at first
sight
[Music]
this is Charles Lala Evans all right
here we go
he and his wife Louise lived in this
house in Starkville Mississippi we will
marry 59 years in 11 months and we will
1 months after 60 years we almost made
60 after she died while I created a
unique tribute to her I decided I do
this in memory of her and we call this
Lala and Louise's place it's his
personal memorial to Louise made up of
thousands of photos this is it this is
it everywhere we went we took pictures
you know you stand over there never make
a good one you stand over here that'll
make a good woody hold it hold it hold
it click we had talked about it before
she passed that one day we want to build
a museum that put these pictures in we
didn't get a chance to do that but the
idea never left my mind and so I said
I'm going to do it anyway
this is 1968 we were going dancing
somewhere back in those days dancing was
a big thing when I first met my wife she
couldn't dance and she just got tired of
that she said you won't teach me how to
do that and after I told her we were
such a smooth couple you know we didn't
we didn't miss a beat man this is my 33
collection fo tops look at that the PO
tops man oh how players 45 see oh man
yeah oh did we issue yes we did this
right here our last dance I'll never
forget it it was in July and I took her
spinning around
dipped it for the last time brought it
back up and put one of them on her you
know
[Music]
the following Friday is when she had a
massive heart attack and she wasn't
responded you know all of a sudden she
looked up at me and said I would melt
you and talk that was it
okay change another god we had such a
beautiful life I got so much to remember
and I'm just living a beautiful memory
we usually get up about 7:00 and I
usually get up a little later
I make coffee for both of us I like
honey and cream and I got bacon and then
I almost always drive to work our
morning routine is quite Monday oh yeah
one thing we're doing today is the
fire-breathing dragon finishing off that
yeah and I've got some stuff to blood
and some skulls and pumpkins I'm Marsha
this is my husband Edie
and we run distortions unlimited we make
monsters zombies aliens dragons and
beasts of all kinds
oh my most of what we make is scary I
will say that we make monsters for
everyone from home Haunter all the way
up to amusement parks and big events all
around the world
[Music]
we've been working together for 35 years
it's been glorious yeah wonderful
[Music]
we started out painting together I fell
in love very quickly we've been married
almost 25 years we found a way to work
together I'm probably more on the
business side and it is probably more in
the production I can't tell you how many
people have told me I could never work
with my spouse and that's too bad
because you miss half or more of that
whole person's life if you don't I think
people expect us to be a little bit
weirder than the yarn we're actually a
little bit boring when we get in the car
and go home it's over
we love monsters we just we've had
enough of it after a long day there's a
separation there there has to be you'd
go crazy if somebody walked into our
house they wouldn't have a clue what we
do in fact we keep it all kind of secret
yeah people are surprised about that
with us we like it that way
it's really special to do something you
love with somebody you love we make
monsters but whatever our personalities
kind of mesh with each other so it works
out you know you really can establish a
good relationship as you're dripping
zombie blood that's the kind of woman I
need in my life
[Music]
you
[Music]